Sudán las partes del conflicto no
parecen querer silenciar las armas el
ejército suspendió su participación en
las conversaciones de tregua con las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido el anuncio lo
hizo un funcionario del gobierno sudanés
quien explicó que la decisión fue tomada
puestos paramilitares nunca respetaron
ningún acuerdo de tregua las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido reaccionaron en Twitter a
pesar del fracaso de las fuerzas armadas
sudanesas en el cese de las hostilidades
las fuerzas de apoyo rápido apoyan
incondicionalmente la iniciativa saudi
estadounidense la recientes violaciones
de las fuerzas armadas sudanesas no nos
han disuadido de cumplir nuestros
compromisos la decisión del ejército no
fue una sorpresa total el lunes los
mediadores estadounidenses y sauditas
anunciaron que las dos partes
prorrogarían por otros cinco días una
tregua humanitaria que debía expirar ese
mismo día pero al día siguiente los
combates volvieron a recrudecer
Incluso el jefe del ejército apareció
arrendando a sus tropas en las calles de
jartum
no queremos destruir el país pero si el
enemigo no obedece nos veremos obligados
a utilizar Nuestra fuerza máxima tras
siete semanas de combates la situación
humanitaria se vuelve cada vez más
preocupante según la ONU 25 millones de
una población de 45 millones necesitan
ayuda para sobrevivir la guerra ha
provocado al menos 1800 muertes y ha
desplazado a casi un millón y medio de
personas entre ellos 350.000 refugiados
unas cifras oficiales ampliamente
subestimadas según los expertos